what is going on YouTube ohhara here
today I want to talk about the right
suits of the German 66 and everything we
know about them I will tell you some
general facts about the suits and then
take a closer look at all six family
members and that distinct looks and
powers as always guys if you aren't
familiar with the one-piece manga
be careful because there will be
spoilers ahead but now without further
ado let's get right into it so guys
before we talk about the individual
members of the VIN smoke family let's
get some general information about the
right suits and the German 66 and the
first thing you should know about the
armor and the raid suits in general is
that they are highly specialized
technologically enhanced armors for
battle they were developed by the
scientists of the German Kingdom and to
a certain extent also by Judge Finn
smoked himself and the suits are made
out of a very special material it is not
only fire resistant but also has the
ability of shape-memory so it basically
remembers who wards and in what shape it
was worn since they seem to be very hard
to produce and the science behind them
seems to be very specific only the
members of the royal family of the
German 66 are allowed to wear eight
suits and that are the VIN smokes so
that means in total there are only six
race suits in existence and now you may
ask yourself what happens when they're
not in use well they're stored inside of
Kalat canisters and each of them is
marked with the personal symbol of the
person who owns it to put the suit on
you click a button on the side of the
canister it then starts rotating and it
releases its content onto the user since
the material has shape memory it
remembers the exact shape of its wearer
and that allows it to very quickly wrap
around the body of its user and in that
form the complete suit now when it comes
to the abilities of the right suit it
gives their users superhuman speed and
also power but it also improves the
natural fighting abilities the VIN
smokes actually admitted that without
their aid suits it would have been very
difficult for them to fight the big bomb
pirates but by being able to make use of
their suits they were actually able to
fight with several of the crews top
fighters on the same level now to make
an example of this
each eg Nietzsche and youngji were
actually able to break Paris
Kandee wall using their gears and that
is saying something because he's after
all the oldest brother of the Chava
family now as we said the rate zoos have
fire resistance so you can actually see
that when big mom uses her heavenly fire
which ray Joo is protected by by her
eight suit and even though she's not
undamaged she would definitely have died
without it also the suits are made of
bulletproof material so they can block
gunfire from even the walker pistols
that are used by the big mom pirates
that are actually able to penetrate
metal however as we see later on they're
not resistant to the special ammunition
that has been developed against the
vince mode family itself we also find
out over the course of the story that
the suits are kind of biometric be
locked that means only the owner can
activate the can itself and some very
special features of the suit are the
boots because they allow their users to
hover in midair jump very large
distances and also it boosts their
kicking power now what is really
interesting in that regard is that Sanji
actually has all of those abilities and
doesn't need the rate suit for it which
speaks for himself but the question may
be asked if the suit then will enhance
those ability further should he ever
decide to use his additionally I also
have three small fun facts for you
regarding the suits first of all the
Cologne soldiers of the German 66 were
very similar suit even though it's not
as strong as we said earlier it's hard
to produce also secondly it is most
likely that the suits were actually
inspired by the Super Sentai which is
kind of a Power Ranger television
franchise in Japan so if you like to
check that out they look really similar
also the material that the rate suits
are made out of this fire resistant and
shape memory having alloy is very
similar to what full metal which is what
Franky Shogun is made out of but now
let's get into the characters and the
family of the VIN smoke family
themselves and I want to start with
judge because he's the head of the
family and he also had a hand in
developing those suits so regarding his
canister it's light gray and it's marked
with a J for judge I assume it also
contains his personal big spear which is
also kind of extracted from the Ken once
he uses it now since the looks of each
of the right suits are a little
different I want to get into that a
little bit too so judge themselves were
a great breasted coat
and it has a white 6 on both sides also
he has a orange cloak and white
gauntlets and a black and orange
jet-propelled boots and his boots are
actually kind of special because they
allow him to lounge himself into the air
and he also has a cape that was actually
able to block Sanji's diablo jumbo power
co a shot so that's pretty impressive
there and it's still only the prototype
kind of suit so next we're gonna get
into rage ooh so rages canisters pink
and it's marked with a big 0 her suit is
an extremely low-cut short pink dress
and it has a purple cloak that is shaped
like a butterfly not a suit as kind of
like small ornaments they're yellow
ovals on pink backgrounds and they can
be found on the end of each wing and on
her boobs and they're basically looking
similar to the number 0 also once she
uses her abilities more ovals appear all
over her she also wears pink gauntlets
and a purple and white route elbow pad
and additionally she also has white and
pink jet-propelled boots and a blue
ascot around her neck her right suit is
ability wise related to her poison
abilities and we know that because it
kind of reacts when she uses her ability
for example when she healed Luffy from
his food poisoning since like mentioned
before those zeros appear on her the
next one in line is the Chi Chi and his
canister is red and it's marked with a
big one
his rage suit is a red and white long
shirt with a yellow 66 on it for German
66 he also has long red pants with a
white pattern a white cloak with a red
one on it and he wears white gauntlets
and white and red jet propeller boots
and she also has a red escort around his
neck now
his power is that he can create small
explosions and send out small energy
blasts so that's a really useful ability
there the next one is the second brother
Nietzsche his canister is blue and is
marked with this to his right suit
consists out of a long blue and yellow
double-breasted shirt and he has pants
with a Lightning pattern on them that
are also blue he also wears a black
cloak which has a blue too on it and
yellow gauntlets and yellow and blue
jet-propelled boots as well and also he
wears a turquoise a skirt around his
neck
now his frayed suit gives him the
ability to channel electricity in his
boots and also in his sort next and last
the line of the Germer we have youngji
and his canister is green and is marked
with a for his rate suit is a green
jumpsuit with a yellow 66 on it a belt
buckle bearing also the Germa 66 symbol
and a black cloak that has the live four
on it he also has lime colored gauntlets
and black and white round elbow pads and
his boots are also lime and kind of
greenish and he also has an orange
escort around his neck
now his suit allows him to have a very
very strong punch by kind of releasing
compressed air in the mechanics in it
and he's also able to extend his reach
of his grip by separating his joints in
his hands now the last person that is
known to have a red suit is Sanji who
got his right suit when he was leaving
all kake island with other straw hats
the color of his canisters are known
since it's only appeared in the manga
and not in the anime so far and it's
marked with a big three and the suit how
it looks and its abilities we have not
yet been shown and we don't know his
Sanji will actually use them in the
future so that is up for speculation I'm
very curious though to what you guys
think about it we'll Sanji used the
right suit or Willie knot or really
maybe give it to someone else and if he
uses it who will he use it against for
the first time and when will it use it
also I would like to know which of the
men smokes in your opinion has the best
power or maybe also the best design so
guys I hope you liked this video if you
did so please leave me a thumbs up if
not leave me a thumbs down share your
thoughts in the comments below and hit
the subscribe button to get notified for
any future content of mine I hope to see
you guys around for the next video and
until then have a great week
you